शीघ्र नमस्कार जय मसीह के हिंदी में के
वृक्ष एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज वैन
सड़क हादसे में हम जर्मन में ना बोलना
सीखने वाले हैं तो जो नाम होना होता है
उसका जर्मन में दो तरीके होते हैं निष्ठ
और गाय दोनों हम देखते हैं सबसे पहले जो
नेक्स्ट है वह हमारे हिंदी जैसा है कि
नहीं मुझे नहीं करना है यह अगर बोलना है
तो वह अनिष्ट होता है मतलब आई प्ले
क्रिकेट अगर आपको बोलना है या फिर आप अगर
बोलना है आए प्ले तो गाइस पिलर डोंट प्ले
स्कूल अनिष्ट लिस्ट को सिर्फ एंड मडर 2 आई
प्ले द गेम आई प्ले जिसके स्पेशल अरदास
पीर आई डोंट प्ले थिस गेम इंक्लूड्स पेस्ट
सिर्फ लिस्ट को एंड में डाल देना है जैसे
हम करते थे वैसे एकदम सिंपल है राइट सिर्फ
अगर आपको याद हो तो मोड व में हम ने क्या
बोला था वो डाल को यूज किया तो मेन वक्त
एकदम हैंड में आ
में पार्टिसिपेट व्हाय वे भी हमने बोला था
अगर इस हवा यूज किया इस बिन यूज किया है
तो गिफ्ट जो भी होगा वह एक कमेंट में
इसीलिए अगर मुझे बोलना है आई कैन नॉट
प्लेसिस कैंप इसका अंदाज़ पे निश स्पीनर
लिस्ट में ही प्रिय उससे भी लगे या फिर
कि आई एम नॉट प्लायड थिस गेम इस ही
बेनिफिशियल निस्ट गैस फील्ड बेसिक बिल्कुल
सिंपल है लिस्ट को जितना पॉसिबल इतना एंड
में जाओ लेकर जाओ पर जो मोड ऑफ बर्थ है या
पार्टिसिपल है उससे भी प्रसिद्ध लेकिन
उसके पीछे जाता है एकदम सिंपल अभी कहते
हैं कि उसमें थोड़ा अर्थ का खेल खेल सकते
हैं मतलब कि जब ऐसे आप आगे जाओगे चीन को
वगैरह तो मतलब जैसे मैं बोल सकता हूं कि
आधा मैं एक कार नहीं खरीदना अगर आपको
बोलना है इश्क़ ख़ुदा संगठन इस इस
परफेक्टली फाइन इश्क फूफा दरगाह टो रिसर्च
पर आपको ऐसे बोल है कि इसको फर्निश्ड
दर्शकों को तो इसका थोड़ा सा मीनिंग क्या
हो जाएगा तो यह गाड़ी नहीं खरीदनी मेरी
में दूसरी खरीद सकता हूं पर वह थोड़ा हायर
लेवल है और यह जनरल यह हमारे हिंदी में भी
यूज नहीं करते तो डोंट वरी अबाउट दिस
दूसरा उसका यूज हो सकता है कि भाई अलग
राशि शनि स्टुअर्ट यह अच्छा नहीं है तो आप
सीरियस किसी सिंपल
आ सकते हो पिछले यह बुरा है वाइट तो
नेक्स्ट को एडजेक्टिव के पहले लिस्ट लगा
सकते हो आप बड़े शेर इजी है उसका अपोजिट
यह टेक्स बोलो तो जैसे मैंने बोला लिस्ट
एकदम सिंपल अपने हिंदी जैसा है लिस्ट को
पकड़ो पुरे सेंटेंस को रिक्वेस्ट करना है
तो एंड में डाल दो पर अगर मूड ऑफ कर दिया
पार्टी शिक्षा है तो उससे पीछे जाए
नेक्स्ट दूसरा जो कर सकते हैं खाएंगे
खाएंगे वह कंसेप्ट किले में ज्यादा नहीं
बोलूंगा कि आप यूज करो इसके दो रीजन है
पहले तो हमारे मराठी हिंदी यह हमारे
भाषाओं में यह कंसेप्ट ज्यादा ऐड नहीं आ
इंग्लिश में हुआ है आई एम नो प्रॉब्लम आई
हैव नो टाइम आ हमरो Idea इसे नो आइडिया है
उसका डायरेक्ट ट्रांसमिशन हमारे भाषाओं
में नहीं है मेरे पास वक्त नहीं है हम
बोलते हो कि डोंट लाइक आई डोंट है होता है
आई एम नॉट टाइम पर डायरेक्ट ट्रांसलेशन
नहीं है अगर करना है तो आप खींचतान के बोल
सकते हो मेरे पास जीरो वक्त मेरे 50 वक्त
है मंडे
सेट करें तो इसीलिए हम को यह यूज करने की
आदत नहीं है तो गरिबवन रिसर्च दूसरे चीज
किया है कि अगर आपको यह खान यूज करना है
अगर आपको यह लाइन यूज करना है तो पूर्ण
उनके साथ यूज करते हो और अगर ना उनके साथ
यूज करते हो तो क्या होगा तो फिर उस पर
चलाना पड़ेगा तो अगर आप यह टेबल देखोगे तो
जैसे आई एम का अपने टेबिल था वैसे खून का
टेबलेट से पाएंगे उनको के लगा तो थैंक यू
नया कुछ नहीं है पर हमेशा बोलते वक्त
सोचना पड़ेगा कि आई हैव नो प्रॉब्लम आए
हैं उन नो प्रॉब्लम प्रॉब्लम क्या है
न्यूट्रल और आपको इफेक्टिव आपको ट्यूटर
होगा टाइम इसीलिए इस हां पक्का इन
प्रॉब्लम पर अगर आई हैव नो टाइम बोलना है
तो साइट थिस
हैंड्स फ्री में शक्ति में लाखों शौक होता
है कई न तो इच्छा मक्खन नाईट बोलना पड़ेगा
थोड़ा सा में से उसको कंप्लीट कर रहे हो
रही तो उसकी जरूरत ही नहीं है जहां तक
पॉसिबल है कि नॉर्मल नीच से नीच सेट करो
सिर्फ हमने राई नाच क्यों सिखाया कि
कभी-कभी स्पेशल अगर आप जर्मनी ने हो तो
जर्मन आपको बोलते खून प्रॉब्लम अगर आप
उनको पता पूछोगे तो मुझे खाना आंऊ तो
बेसिकली इट मींस जब मुझे तो पता नहीं कोई
आईडिया नहीं है इस बारे में या फिर अरे
कोई प्रॉब्लम है आसफ खान प्रॉब्लम्स
बेसिकली फ्रॉम न खाए इंवॉल्वेस कट बेवर्ड
माय डियर तो ए गुड टो नो थिस अगर आपको यूज
करना है तो हम यूज भी कर सकते हो परिसर
में दीजिए क्योंकि स्क्रीन रखाइन क्रिकेट
की जगह स्पिनर क्रिकेट निशान इसी इजी है
ना यह थोड़ा हमारी भाषाओं जैसा है ज्यादा
लॉजिकल तो जैसे मैंने बोला अगर आपको नेट
यूज करना है तो वेरी सिंपल पुरे सेंटेंस
को नेकेड
आधे रेट उसको एडमिट लेकर जाओ सिर्फ में
डाल व पार्टिसिपल को तो उसमें क्या होता
है वह उससे भी ज्यादा पीछे जाते हैं ये
एसिड अब टुकड़े को भी ऐड कर सकते हैं और
नेट सेटर इज नॉट रियली नीड और खान का
मैंने बोला कि यू शोल्ड नो थिस लाइंस खान
प्रॉब्लम खान ने आलू वगैरह पर जब आप यूज
करोगे तो उसको ज्यादा यूज करने की जरूरत
नहीं है अगर करोगे तो केयरफुल रहना कि
उसको आखिरी ना चलाना पड़ेगा मुझे आशा है
कि आपको यह अंदर ठीक से समझ में आया होगा
या फिर मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में
धन्यवाद